now we need to go to community by
community neighborhood by neighborhood
and often door-to-door literally
knocking on doors
to get help to the remaining people
protected from the virus
dr nicole sapphire joins us now she's a
fox news contributor and author of the
book panic attack
i know when i heard that i thought okay
well he's trying to give it a shot
to get people more information uh why
the backlash do you agree with it
so well dana i mean the president found
himself in a bit of a dichotomy during
that speech at one hand he was declaring
an independence from this virus and he's
right because americans have the
opportunity to choose to be vaccinated
to protect themselves and their loved
ones
from this pandemic but declaring that
independence doesn't mean the pandemic
is over
but now all of a sudden he says and by
the way we're going to send grassroots
low-level government workers to your
house and while
some people may see this as a public
education
push which is always a good thing the
more education the better
other people may see this as
confrontational and i can tell you dana
that's not how you're going to reach
that vaccine hesitant population by
sending people to their house they're
going to already feel that you're
invading their space
yeah dr um nicole listen to this from
dan crenshaw congressman from down in
houston he says
how about don't knock on my door you're
not my parents you're the government
make the vaccine available and let
people be free to choose
why is that concept so hard for the left
so i think that's
one of the things you're saying i also
noted today that in the washington post
said in maryland
100 people died of covid in june in
maryland
and 100 of them were unvaccinated and
that was one of the things that the
president was trying to say yesterday i
suppose
well and that's not just maryland that's
many states across the country and other
countries are seeing that as well yes
the
the deaths that are still occurring from
stars kobe 2 are
tend to be those that are unvaccinated
so the best way to protect people
is to get vaccinated but again this is a
freedom of choice
and that is what is very important it
goes to the core of our
country when you turn on other media
outlets you actually hear people calling
for
um requiring them and mandates and if
you you can't declare independence and
the
freedom to choose vaccination and then
require them as well and say we're going
to be sending government officials
these are conversations that need to be
had between physicians and patients
and not by low-level grassroots people
knocking on doors
the other thing i've really noticed in
the past few days um it's been building
but a lot of the headlines are all um
targeted and sort of blaming
anyone who voted for trump or the red
states and they're the ones that was a
problem now a lot of those places are
rural some of them don't have the
fancy freezers that could take the
pfizer modern vaccines that johnson
johnson might be more available but
how would you persuade someone at this
point to get the vaccine what do you
think is the best approach
well listen dana there was a lot of
politization throughout the entire
course of the
vaccines but the best thing that the
current cdc and the administration could
do right now is to reach out to those
vaccine hesitants
and that has to do with getting full fda
approval of these vaccines i think you
will really
help people trust the safety more if you
get that full approval they have the
data to do that they can
they need to be transparent they can't
be so myopic when it comes to the
adolescent recommendations
especially as we see a rise in cases of
the myocarditis
they are continued to neglect natural
immunity and they continue to
to recommend full dose for these
adolescents regardless of
risk and regardless of presence of
natural immunity if they actually did
that i think that they would gain the
trust of the american people more
this has nothing to do with trump when
it comes to the rural populations yes
you have to make sure that it's
available to them right and you have to
make sure that they have the education
and the way to do that is to reach out
to the local public health officials
and the trusted physicians in the area
not send government to their homes
all right dr nicole sapphire great to
have you this morning thank you